À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
La Seconde Guerre mondiale...
Berlin sous les bombes
des Alliés...
Des soldats nazis
à tous les coins de rue...
N'est-ce pas le meilleur endroit
où atterrir
pour nos personnages ?
Eliot le robot,
Iris la voyageuse temporelle
et Thomas le...
Thomas, quoi.
Se rapprochent des traces
du Docteur Simon,
porté disparu.
Putain de nazis de merde !
Ah ouais, je comprends mieux
pourquoi t'étais pas
très emballée par cette époque.
Parce que c'est la guerre.
Fuyons la zone de combat.
- Par ici.
- Waouh !
Ils ont tout fait comme
dans Call of Duty, n'empêche.
Mais t'es vraiment trop con !
Bon, attendez, faut que je fasse
un truc avec ma robe,
là, c'est hyper chiant
pour se déplacer.
On enlève les manches...
Hop !
Thomas, prends le bout de verre,
là, et raccourcis-moi la robe.
Euh... OK, oui.
Euh, OK, d'accord.
Attends, t'es sérieux, là ?
C'est beaucoup trop court !
Euh, je sais pas,
dans les mangas,
c'est la longueur normale.
Maintenant, ce sera
plus pratique pour te déplacer.
C'est pour mater mon cul, ouais.
Bon, il me reste plus
qu'à changer de pompes.
Ah, bah, tiens, je vais
prendre celles du monsieur, là.
Elles seront un peu grandes,
mais ça va le faire.
Iris, ce sont les chaussures
d'un soldat mort, t'as vu, ça ?
Et maintenant,
c'est les miennes.
Ah, bah, voilà !
On est mieux, là.
Le diadème de reine sur ta tête
va te gêner aussi.
Ah non, non, ça, je le garde.
- C'est trop stylé.
- Là, des intrus !
- Vous, qui êtes-vous ?
- Euh, bah...
Moi, c'est Thomas.
Chers soldats, on s'est perdus
sur le champ de bataille.
Nous sommes berlinois,
nous parlons parfaitement
allemand, vous entendez ?
Mais moi, je parle pas du tout
un seul mot d'allemand.
Ta gueule !
Oui, vous avez raison.
Votre allemand est parfait.
Vous avez rien à faire ici,
la ville est à feu et à sang.
Allez vous mettre à l'abri.
- Heil Hitler !
- Heil Hitler...
Vous avez entendu ?
Je parle très bien allemand,
en fait.
J'avais pas remarqué.
Pas du tout,
je possède un traducteur actif
qui traduit toutes les langues
dans un large périmètre.
C'est pour ça que le soldat
pensait qu'on parlait allemand.
Tu t'es pas demandé pourquoi
les Anglais te parlaient
en français, tout à l'heure ?
On n'était pas en France,
tout à l'heure ?
- On était au Pays de Galles !
- Bah, c'est en France.
- C'est au Royaume-Uni !
- Ah ! Et France Gall, alors ?
- Famille héritière de...
- Oh, regardez !
Y a quelqu'un qui vient
de se téléporter devant nous !
- Sacrebleu ! Où suis-je ?
-Elle me dit quelque chose.
C'est la voleuse de ma machine.
Ah oui, ça me revient.
Aliénor, rends-moi ma machine !
Où nous trouvons-nous,
Dame Iris ?
Encore de la sorcellerie ?
Sommes-nous en enfer ?
Non, nous sommes à Berlin.
Reprenez-lui ma machine !
Sale voleuse !
Mais c'est vous
qui avez volé mon trône,
avec votre sorcellerie.
Aliénor...
Et si c'est cet objet
que vous convoitez tant...
- Aliénor !
- Alors, je le garde.
Et peut-être que...
- Oh, la connasse !
- Ah, bah, elle est partie.
Elle est repartie
avec ma machine.
Y avait une chance sur combien
pour qu'elle apparaisse
devant nous, comme ça ?
100 %.
La machine est programmée
pour revenir à son propriétaire.
La machine est en mode shuffle.
Elle voyage aléatoirement
dans le temps et l'espace.
Mais elle va bien finir
par revenir.
Et là, paf, on récupère
ma putain de machine !
J'ai rien compris,
mais ça marche.
D'ailleurs, Iris, qu'est-ce que
tu faisais dans un château ?
On est obligés
d'en parler maintenant ?
J'aime bien voyager.
Moi aussi, j'aime bien voyager,
mais quand je vais en Espagne,
je cherche pas
à devenir le pape.
C'est au Vatican.
Bon, j'aime bien voyager
dans le temps.
Mon père a inventé
cette machine,
alors ça fait un an
que je change d'époque
pour découvrir le monde.
Comment t'expliquer...
Imagine que je suis
en Erasmus temporel.
La trace du Docteur Simon
est très faible.
C'est très difficile
de le localiser.
Oh, merde, ça nous arrange
pas du tout, ça.
On est comme des cons
sous les bombardements
des Américains.
- Excusez-moi...
- Qui a parlé, là ?
Baisse les yeux,
c'est un petit garçon.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ici,
mon chou ?
C'est dangereux, hein.
Y a des bombes
qui tombent du ciel.
Je suis perdu.
Je cherche mes parents.
Où les as-tu vus
pour la dernière fois ?
Dans un train.
J'étais avec mes parents
et mon papy.
Attends, tu viens d'où,
exactement ?
Bah... de France.
On est montés dans un train.
La SNCF était gentille,
c'était gratuit.
Oh, merde...
La chance,
il prend le train gratos !
Non, pas la chance du tout, non.
Toute une famille dans un train
direction l'est
dans les années 40,
ça te rappelle rien ?
Vu comme tu le dis, ça devrait ?
L'Holocauste, Thomas.
C'est dans Call of Duty.
Ah !
Mais je regarde pas
les cinématiques, c'est pour ça.
Mais comment j'ai pu sortir
avec toi ?
Bon, écoute, mon petit.
On sait pas où sont tes parents,
mais reste près de nous,
tu seras plus en sécurité.
Je vais retrouver ma famille ?
Le risque qu'ils soient encore
en vie est proche de 0...
Mais oui, ils vont bien !
Ils vont bien, chéri.
Merci, vous êtes gentils.
Pas comme le monsieur
de tout à l'heure.
Ah oui...
Fais attention aux soldats.
Ils peuvent être très méchants
envers... toi
et ton peuple.
C'était un monsieur bizarre
avec une blouse blanche,
qui est apparu comme par magie.
Il m'a posé des questions,
et après,
il m'a laissé tout seul ici.
Ça ressemble à la description
du Docteur Simon.
Petit enfant,
est-ce que c'est lui ?
- Oui, c'est ça.
- C'est mon père.
Génial, on va pouvoir
le retrouver !
Intéressant.
Ton père abandonne
les enfants juifs.
Oui, bah, ça va, hein !
Il avait la tête ailleurs.
Enfin, je crois.
Alors, dis-nous où il est allé,
le monsieur.
Là-bas, dans le grand bâtiment
avec les grandes croix.
Très bien, c'est un QG nazi.
Rendons-nous là-bas.
- Super ! Allons-y !
- Euh...
Je suis pas sûre que ce soit
l'endroit idéal pour toi, chéri.
D'accord, donc on le laisse
sous les bombes, alors.
Oui, bon, ça va, hein !
Allez, viens, petit.
Reste avec nous.
- Mais fais-toi discret.
- Oui, Madame.
Avec un peu de chance,
mon père est encore là-bas.
Au début, il était très gentil,
comme vous.
Et après, il était méchant,
il m'a frappé.
T'as dû avoir
une enfance difficile, Iris.
Dis-moi, mon petit, il t'a fait
des attouchements ?
- Des quoi ?
- Mon père ne ferait jamais ça !
N'importe quoi...
On est arrivés.
Cachez-vous derrière les débris.
Oh, merde, mais pourquoi
mon père est venu
dans un QG nazi ?
- C'est infesté de soldats.
- Allez, on y va !
Mais non ! Petit, reste ici !
Reviens, reviens !
Y a des soldats partout !
Il va pouvoir retrouver
sa famille... dans les cieux.
Arrête ! C'est tellement triste.
Ah, Lucien !
Où étais-tu passé ?
- Mais attends...
- T'as vu Papy ?
Le gamin est en train
de discuter avec les soldats.
Ils le prennent
dans leurs bras ?
Ah, oui.
Le soldat l'a mis sur son dos.
Il fait du dada.
Ça se passe très bien pour lui,
finalement.
Mes copains, tu veux
que je te les présente ?
- Ils sont là-bas. Les copains !
- Oh, il vient vers nous.
Et voilà mes copains.
Très bien, mon petit Lucien.
Vous pouvez entrer.
Faites comme chez vous.
On est de la même famille.
Non, je pense pas
qu'on soit de la même...
Lucien,
va retrouver tes parents.
- Ils sont dans le QG.
- Oui !
Mais ne va pas déranger Papy.
Il a une réunion
très importante.
Entrez, chers amis.
- Heil Hitler !
Heil Hitler...
Merci de m'avoir aidé
à retrouver mes parents.
Euh, petit...
Tu viens d'où, exactement,
en France ?
- De la capitale.
- Paris ?
Vichy.
- Mais il fait quoi, ton papy ?
- Il est maréchal.
C'est le maréchal Pétain.
Vous connaissez ?
- Oh, putain...
- Waouh !
Si seulement je savais
qui c'est.
Du coup, mon petit,
tu n'es pas juif ?
N'importe quoi !
Ma race est supérieure.
Ah, bah, nickel !
On est tombés
sur un enfant nazi.
Bon, écoute, Lucien... Pétain.
Les hommes sont tous égaux.
Y a pas de race supérieure.
Non, c'est pas vrai !
- Lucien, dis pas des bêtises.
- Non, je dis pas des bêtises !
En attendant,
moi, je sais où il est,
le monsieur avec la blouse.
C'est vrai ? Dis-nous.
Alors dites "la race aryenne
est supérieure",
et je vous dis où il est.
Très bien.
La race aryenne est su...
Eliot, ne dis pas
n'importe quoi !
Il suffit de dire ça,
et il nous donne l'information.
Non, on dira jamais ça, non.
C'est raciste.
Non, c'est vous, les nuls !
Vous saurez jamais
que le monsieur,
il est allé
dans la bibliothèque.
- Oubliez ça.
- La bibliothèque ?
Ne partez pas !
Gardes ! Des juifs !
Ta gueule !
Bravo, Iris,
tu viens d'assommer un enfant.
- C'est de famille, on dirait.
- Arrête tes conneries.
Déjà que j'aime pas les enfants,
mais alors, les enfants nazis...
Cassons-nous avant
que les gardes débarquent.
La bibliothèque est à l'étage.
Le Docteur Simon
s'y trouve peut-être encore.
Là !
La porte de la bibliothèque.
- Thomas, tu fais quoi ?
- Hein ?
Bah, je me recoiffe, c'est tout.
Non, mais c'est pour faire
bonne impression.
Enfin, je sais pas,
c'est ton père.
Quand même, un moment,
faut être un peu présentable.
On n'est plus ensemble, Thomas.
Alors, c'était pas du tout
pour toi du tout.
- C'était juste...
- On rentre.
-Super, bah, voilà...
Peut-être que...
- Was ?
- Oh, putain !
Encore des intrus
dans ma bibliothèque !
- C'est Hitler.
- Attends, mais...
Ton père, c'est Hitler ?
Comment ça ?
Adolf Hitler
est le père d'Iris ?
Pas du tout,
mais alors pas du tout !
C'est un hasard.
Oui, en Allemagne, en 1944,
on peut tomber sur Hitler.
C'est un fait.
Mais nos personnages
se rapprochent-ils
ou s'éloignent-ils
du Docteur Simon ?
Chaud ? Froid ? Tiède ?
Vous n'allez pas le croire,
mais moi, je le sais.
Ah, si, vous êtes au courant.
Vous savez que je savais.
À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
On se retrouve, cher auditeur.
Toujours à la recherche
du père d'Iris,
nos trois compagnons
tombent plutôt sur... Hitler.
C'est vraiment ballot.
Et j'ai comme l'impression
qu'il n'est pas du genre
à laisser passer des inconnus
dans sa bibliothèque
personnelle.
C'est comme ça, les dictateurs
n'aiment pas être dérangés,
tout le monde sait ça.
Que faites-vous
dans ma bibliothèque ?
Qui êtes-vous ?
Avec vos costumes extravagants,
c'est pas très Hugo Boss,
tout ça,
surtout la jupe très courte,
mein Fräulein.
Merde,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Eliot, pourquoi il parle
avec l'accent ?
T'es pas censé tout traduire ?
Si, mais je trouve ça
plus marrant.
Quel est ce personnage
métallique ?
C'est, euh...
un modèle de tank sur pieds.
Ah, ein petit Panzer...
Sehr gut !
Et il en faut beaucoup
pour gagner contre Staline
et les Américains.
Et il fait même le café.
Vous en voulez ?
Avec plaisir,
avec beaucoup de lait.
J'aime pas
quand c'est trop noir.
Et voilà le café.
Vous allez voir,
c'est une tuerie.
- Tu sers un café à Hitler ?
- Danke schön.
- Tu sais qui c'est, au moins ?
- Mais oui, je sais qui c'est.
Je suis pas con, j'ai joué
à Wolfenstein, merci.
Et puis, il sait peut-être
où est ton père ?
Et puis là,
il a rien fait de mal...
Il a rien fait de mal ?
Oui, bah, il a rien fait de mal
maintenant.
Et puis, je sais pas,
il est accueillant...
Mais tu parles d'un dictateur
qui décime des populations !
Qu'est-ce que vous venez
de dire ?
Vous parlez au Führer !
Vous voulez goûter une balle
de mon Luger P08 ?
Non, Monsieur Hitler,
tout va bien.
On parlait de... Staline.
Oh, mon petit Panzer
sait parler.
Bon, je laisse couler.
C'est bien parce que le monsieur
m'a offert un café au lait.
Sehr gut, en passant.
Comment je viens
de nous sauver la vie, sérieux !
Vous aussi, vous êtes là
pour me prendre un livre
de ma collection personnelle ?
Comment ça ?
Un monsieur en blouse blanche
m'a pris un livre
juste avant que vous arriviez.
Mais comme c'était un carnet
insipide écrit par un juif,
je lui ai donné.
Il parle de mon père, là.
Vous savez où il est parti ?
Ach, wunderbar !
Il a disparu sous mes yeux.
C'est probablement
mes caporaux SS
qui m'ont offert
un petit spectacle surprise.
Iris, le carnet,
c'est peut-être une piste.
- Il faut creuser.
- Euh... Le carnet, là...
- Vous pouvez nous en parler ?
- Ach !
C'était un cadeau
d'un de mes adjudants.
Un carnet de notes d'un juif
qui écrivait de la science.
C'était un certain... Einstein.
Ton père est venu chercher
des notes de Einstein ?
C'est sûrement
pour ses recherches
sur le temps.
Thomas, rassure-moi.
Tu sais qui c'est, Einstein ?
Mais bien sûr,
c'est le mec de l'expression :
"Je suis pas Einstein, moi !",
je le dis souvent.
Ah oui, oui, c'est sûr
que t'es pas Einstein, toi.
Mais où est-ce qu'il est allé,
mon père, ensuite ?
Hitler peut nous aider
à savoir.
- Euh...
- J'ai chaud.
À tout hasard, Monsieur Adolf,
le monsieur à la blouse
aurait pas parlé
d'une destination future ?
- Non, non ?
-Nein, nein... Ach, ja !
Juste avant de disparaître,
il a dit : "Direction 1644
sur l'île de la Réunion."
Est-ce que ça peut vous aider ?
Bah, oui, oui, c'est pas mal.
Je vais ouvrir la fenêtre
pour aérer un peu.
J'ai effectivement un voyage
du Docteur Simon
à cette période sur mon rapport.
Parfait.
On dépose Thomas à son époque
et direction...
l'île de la Réunion.
Oh, non, pas encore !
Non, non, mais je vous suis.
Moi, je peux être super utile.
Regardez.
Hitler a failli nous tuer,
mais il nous a trouvés
sympathiques.
- Grâce à qui ?
- Grâce à mon café.
Mais c'était mon idée.
Iris, dis-lui
que je peux être super utile.
Je vais quand même ouvrir
un peu plus grand...
Iris ? Iris ?
Qu'est-ce que tu regardes ?
-Pour profiter du soleil.
- Bougez pas.
Quel joli jour de printemps !
Ah, ça fait du bien !
Mais Iris,
tu viens de tuer Hitler !
C'est bon, Eliot,
on se téléporte
avant qu'on ait des emmerdes.
Iris, tu viens de sauver
le monde, t'as tué Hitler !
Non, pas vraiment, non.
C'est plus compliqué.
Hitler est décédé !
C'est terminé, la guerre,
les morts et tout !
Dans ce monde-là, oui.
Mais dans ton époque ou
dans la mienne, ça change rien.
Vu le regard de Thomas,
j'ai l'impression
qu'il n'a rien compris.
Je suis pas Einstein, moi.
Vos trucs de voyage
dans le temps,
les gens meurent,
les gens meurent pas,
je suis désolé,
mais c'est compliqué.
On peut changer de temps,
mais aussi de monde.
Il existe une infinité de Thomas
comme une infinité de Hitler.
Bon, regarde.
Eliot, on revient
quelques secondes plus tôt,
s'il te plaît.
Approchez-vous.
Retemporalisation immédiate.
J'ai failli basculer
par la fenêtre.
- Et voilà, regarde.
- Ach ! Je vais ouvrir...
On retrouve Adolf.
La fenêtre pour profiter
du soleil...
On le retrouve plus.
Et en plus, ça soulage.
T'as compris ? Vas-y, à toi.
Eliot, en arrière.
Ach !
Je vais quand même ouvrir...
Allez, vas-y, Thomas, pousse-le.
Mais je vais pas
tuer quelqu'un de...
Il ne sera mort
que dans ce monde,
ça n'a aucune importance.
Et puis, c'est Hitler,
vas-y, ça soulage.
Bon, OK, juste pour voir.
Monsieur Hitler ?
- Ja ?
- Excusez-moi.
Qu'y a-t-il ?
Ouais, ça fait du bien !
Mais je suis pas un meurtrier ?
Bah non, on s'en fout, c'est
le voyage dans le temps.
Eliot ?
Encore une fois, s'il te plaît.
Allez, une dernière.
La fenêtre.
Ach, je vais ouvrir...
Ah, c'est génial !
On a assez poussé Hitler,
on peut y aller ?
Oui, oui, pardon. Eh !
Laissez-moi venir avec vous.
Juste à la prochaine
destination.
S'il vous plaît...
Bon...
- Et tâche de rester en vie.
-Yes !
Eliot,
allons retrouver mon père.
Approchez-vous.
Trace temporelle synchronisée.
Direction... 1644
sur... l'île de la Réunion.
Retemporalisation immédiate.
On devrait pas se retrouver
sur une île, plutôt ?
Là, on est dans une cabane
qui bouge.
On est dans un bateau.
Le voyage dans le temps
n'est pas parfaitement précis.
L'île doit être juste à côté.
Ça aurait pu être pire.
On aurait pu tomber dans l'eau
et mourir noyés.
Très rassurant, Eliot...
Merci beaucoup.
Bon, on sort de là.
Euh... C'est fermé.
Comment ça, c'est fermé ?
Pousse-toi.
Ah ouais, merde,
on est enfermés !
Oh putain, on est enfermés
dans les geôles
des cales d'une frégate !
Waouh !
T'en as, du vocabulaire,
en fait.
Ouais,
c'est parce que j'ai joué
à Assassin's Creed : Black Flag.
J'ai saigné le jeu.
Eh, mais...
Ça sent pas le cramé ?
Laissez-moi utiliser
mes capteurs olfactifs.
- Oui, ça sent le cramé.
- Mais c'est normal !
Regardez derrière les barreaux :
des flammes !
- Le bateau est en feu !
- Oh, putain !
Eliot,
téléporte-nous ailleurs !
Vous allez rire, mais avec
votre Hitler que vous avez tué
un paquet de fois, je n'ai plus
de batterie pour voyager
dans le temps.
Est-ce que tu vois
quelqu'un rire, ici ?
J'aurais vraiment préféré
être téléportée dans l'eau.
- Je prends note.
- Non, non, ne prends pas note.
Oh, les clés !
Je vois les clés
derrière les barreaux,
au bout du couloir, là,
sur le bureau, regardez !
- Eliot, fais quelque chose !
- Un café ?
Non, mais Eliot...
Avec deux sucres, s'il te plaît.
Non, mais putain,
vous servez à rien !
On va mourir ici !
J'aurais jamais dû vous suivre.
Vous m'écouterez, ainsi !
Comment ?
Encore un nouvel endroit
maléfique ?
Aliénor !
Elle est derrière la grille.
- Aliénor, coucou !
- Oh !
Me voilà en enfer !
Je sens les flammes.
- Ici !
- Ah !
Que vois-je ?
Mais vous êtes enfermés.
Les clés !
Jette-nous les clés !
Elles sont derrière toi.
Et pourquoi devrais-je
faire ça, Dame Iris ?
N'êtes-vous pas dans un endroit
que vous méritez ?
- Oh, la connasse...
- Reine Aliénor, écoutez-nous.
Iris n'est absolument pas
maléfique.
L'occasion d'accéder
à votre trône,
bah... s'est présentée à elle.
Est-ce que vous auriez reculé,
à sa place ?
Non, vous auriez fait
comme elle.
Et est-ce qu'elle vous a coupé
la tête ?
Non, elle vous a gardée
près d'elle.
Alors pardonnez-la, donnez-nous
les clés, reine Aliénor.
Par pitié.
Il commence à faire très chaud.
Bien. Je vous donne les clés.
Mais je vous laisse
à votre sort.
- Et je garde la boîte magique.
- Ça marche. Merci, Aliénor.
Et merci, Thomas.
Ces clés-là ?
- Ah... Elle est plus là.
- Quoi ?
- Les clés non plus.
- Elle s'est téléportée ?
Avec les clés ?
On est foutus, on va mourir.
- Oh, merde, merde...
- Iris a raison.
Putain, on va mourir.
Nos chances de survie
sont proches de... 1 %.
Libéré, délivré
Oh, et arrête
avec cette chanson à la con !
Désolé, c'était
pour détendre l'atmosphère.
Qu'ai-je entendu ?
Une chanson ?
C'est qui, lui ?
Y a-t-il des âmes à secourir
dans ce bateau en flammes ?
- Ici !
- Mon Dieu !
- J'arrive tout de suite.
Tiens, voilà le 1 %.
N'ayez crainte,
je vais ouvrir cette porte
à l'aide de ma force.
Reculez-vous,
je prends un peu d'élan...
- Personne n'est blessé ?
- Merci, vous nous avez sauvés !
C'est normal.
Je parcours les terres
et les mers pour secourir
les personnes en danger.
Vite, sortons d'ici avant que...
Et lui, c'est qui ?
En voilà un
qui a goûté à ma hache !
Et j'en vois trois autres
qui veulent être découpés
en morceaux
par le célébrissime pirate
La Buse.
Qu'est-ce qui est mieux ?
Être enfermé
dans un bateau en feu
ou se retrouver
face à un pirate sanguinaire
dans un bateau en feu ?
Pas besoin de choisir
pour Iris, Eliot et Thomas :
ce sera la hache du pirate.
Rendez-vous au prochain épisode
pour savoir en combien
de morceaux ils seront découpés.